all across planet internet people are
turning chips into a construction
material but is completing a chip circle
really possible
this is Ontario's furious Pete taking up
the challenge okay maybe not
they say patience is a virtue but not if
you're furious Pete if at first you
don't succeed change flavors will the
sour cream chips enable Pete to become
Lord of the Ring and how is be going
full circle in order to provide enough
structural support to the top of the
Ring he has built two very large bases
called cantilevers as he's building the
cantilevers he puts one chip down they
needs another chip on top to hold it so
it doesn't slip off and then if he wants
to add another chip outside of that he
needs to had more chips back here by
building both come to leave as
simultaneously he builds a very thick
and solid base and then at a certain
point instead of his cantilevers going
out they start to go in and he needs to
make sure those are balanced as these
works his way to the middle it's a
subtle balance between the number of
chips used and where they're placed on
the ring that creates the perfect
structure